nasa's space shuttle program was
revolutionary
as it was the first major step at
regularizing space travel
and introducing the concept of rocket
reusability
however one realm in which it was now
revolutionary
was cost despite one of the main
promises of the space shuttle being
cheaper space flight
like with most other government
sponsored programs this space shuttle
program
fell flat on its face clocking in at a
total
of 209 billion dollars or
1.6 billion dollars per launch
to put this in perspective the spacex
crew dragon
costs 209 million dollars per launch
meaning that with the 209
billion dollars nasa could have launched
1 000 crew dragons
as opposed to the 134 space shuttle
flights
on top of this spacex is aiming to
eventually push down their pre-launch
cost of their new rocket
starship to just 2 million so
why did it cost nasa so much and
why are spacex's solutions so much
[Music]
cheaper
we get into this video i want to preface
that this video
is by no means intended to hate on nasa
or any of their outstanding
accomplishments
space flight wouldn't be what it is
today without nasa
and this video is simply supposed to
highlight the operational differences
between nasa and spacex that have led to
an economical viability gap
with that being said one of the biggest
mistakes of the space shuttle program
was being too ambitious instead of
improving upon the apollo design
and figuring out ways to cut costs nasa
decided to construct a brand new vehicle
basically from scratch aside from a
brand new design nasa
packed in as much technology as they
could into the space shuttle
which made it one of the most complex
rockets ever built
this led to some pretty hefty
development costs
but more importantly this made repairs
and
maintenance a nightmare during the idea
development phase
many simpler designs were suggested and
looking back
an incremental upgrade would have likely
been a much better choice
as it would have significantly reduced
the number of unanticipated issues
next up this space shuttle program was
run for
way too long originally in 1972
then nasa administrator james fletcher
proposed to congress that the shuttle
would cost 5.15 billion dollars to
develop
and boast a per launch cost of just 10.5
million dollars
nasa was actually pretty spot on with
the development costs
they did slightly overrun the proposed
5.15 billion
but that's basically a given with every
new development
very quickly though it became clear that
the space shuttle would cost a minimum
of 20 times their projected per launch
cost at
over 200 million dollars while very high
that's actually okay they tried
something new
and it didn't quite pan out what blew
out of proportions however
was that they originally only planned on
using the space shuttle for 10 to 15
years
but as we all know this ended up being
2-3
times longer at 30 years at the same
time though
this is not all nasa's fault around the
time the space shuttle was supposed to
retire
was when the international space station
construction went into full gear
the iss was actually approved during the
reagan presidency
in 1984 but the planning and development
phase
far exceeded what they originally
anticipated despite garnering approval
in 1984
the final design of the iss was not
picked until 1993
and it wasn't until 1998 that the space
shuttle
was first used to launch iss elements
into orbit
at the time the space shuttle was the
only vehicle that could carry many of
the iss parts
into space and given all the delays
already
nasa wasn't going to design a new rocket
to take these parts into orbit
consequently nasa was forced to continue
using the very expensive space shuttle
until the end of the iss construction
the iss
ended up adding nearly two decades onto
the lifespan of the space shuttle
program
and tens of billions if not over a
hundred billion dollars
onto the cost to make things worse the
international space station
is quickly reaching the end of its
lifetime
nasa says that the space station can
easily last 30 years
if not much more however the lifespan
of the space station itself is
irrelevant as
nasa plans to step away from supporting
the space station by 2024
in order to divert the funding to other
projects so
at the end of the day it's pretty
questionable if it was worth running the
space shuttle program
for another two decades to build an iss
from an economical standpoint
from an achievement standpoint however
the iss
is no doubt one of the greatest feats of
humanity
so it can definitely be argued that the
space shuttle's exorbitant cost
was justified as it made the iss
possible
and finally that brings me on to the
last
and probably the biggest drawback of the
space shuttle
which was that it lacked a clearly
defined goal
yeah it was meant to create sustainable
space travel
but this clearly wasn't the primary goal
as
we likely would have seen a simpler more
economically friendly design
if this was the case at the same time
public excitement started to dwindle as
america
had already gotten people onto the moon
and
beat the ussr in their own race from the
viewpoint of the average individual
the next big space achievement that
would get them excited
was getting to mars not lowering the
cost of space travel
though lowering the cost is crucial to
getting to mars
for the average person it's not that
exciting
as a result this space shuttle didn't
really have a purpose
it didn't have a clearly defined goal it
didn't have anyone to beat
and it didn't garner massive public
support like the apollo program
even the construction of the iss using
the space shuttle was
mostly an afterthought and this left the
space shuttle
just randomly wandering in the
wilderness of space
so that's some of the main reasons that
the space shuttle failed
but how did spacex correct all these
mistakes and
actually bring down the cost to space
travel well
starting off one of the key advantages
for spacex
is that they just had one goal reduce
cost
without compromising safety that's it
nothing more
nothing less sure they have other
aspirations like getting to mars
and providing speedy travel within the
earth but
what do all of these center around
reducing cost
as elon musk has said most government
space organizations have spent decades
focusing on just performance as opposed
to reducing cost
and as government funding of space
organizations has been on a downward
trend
this has become more of a concern aside
from this
a major benefit for spacex is that
they're run like a startup
as opposed to nasa which is more run
like the government
a large benefit of any government job is
that individuals
are usually not overworked as government
organizations
stick pretty closely to the 40 hours a
week schedule
and this is also true when it comes to
nasa
nasa employees are expected to work 40
hours per week
monday through friday during regular
business hours of 8 am
to 4 30 pm this is ideal for employees
and should be how all organizations are
run but
this is obviously not the case at spacex
the average employee works a minimum of
60 hours per week
with work extending into the 80 to 100
hour range on a regular basis
oftentimes this even crosses the 100
hour threshold
during important launches and recoveries
working weekends and
shifts around the clock are also quite
common
of course all of these engineers and
manufacturing workers
are doing this voluntarily as they can
likely
easily find a less demanding and higher
paying job
elsewhere but all of them have been sold
into the vision of spacex and are fine
with dedicating that many hours into
work
whether this is healthy or safe from a
psychological and mental perspective
this no doubt significantly reduces cost
as each employee is nearly twice as
productive
as the average nasa employee and the
last competitive advantage
for spacex compared to nasa is of course
competition spacex is a private company
and thus they aren't handed a set amount
of money from the government
on a yearly basis as a result spacex has
to compete with giants like boeing
and nasa themselves to win contracts
from nasa
as well as keep investor confidence high
with such
pressure on a regular basis it's really
no wonder why
the spacex team has been working so hard
to bring down the cost of space travel
as much as people like to say that the
only person you should try to beat
is yourself it's no doubt that having
tangible competition
increases the pressure to succeed and
continue improving
this was the case with nasa in the 1960s
and is the case with spacex today with
all that being said the main reasons the
space shuttle program cost so much
was being overly ambitious running too
long
and a lack of competition and purpose
meanwhile the economical success of
spacex
can mostly be attributed to a clear
vision startup culture
and a high level of competition driving
them forward
but really at the end of the day both of
these organizations
have been and will continue to be
crucial to future space exploration
and colonization so it's awesome that
they were able to partner up
and get to a position in which they can
both constantly learn from each other
and improve themselves moving forward
who do you guys think is more
revolutionary for space travel
the ones who made it possible or the
ones who are making it viable
comment that down below also if you guys
appreciate this analysis
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]
you